On those cold, rainy days when you forget your rain jacket or umbrella...
...and you want to stay as dry as possible,...
...should you walk and spend more time in the rain?
Or should you run, which means you'll be hitting more raindrops from the side?
Assuming you haven't been fully soaked yet...
...and you aren't jumping into puddles, the answer is simple.
As you move out of the way of one falling raindrop, you move into the way of another.
So the amount of rain hitting the top of you is constant,...
...regardless of how fast you're going.
If you're not moving, the rain from the top is all you'll get.
But if you are moving, you'll also run into raindrops from the side...
...and you'll get wetter.
So in any given second, you stay driest by standing still,...
...and the faster you move, the wetter you become.